in the last video we defined our random
variable x is the number of heads we get
after flipping a coin five times and
it's a it's a fair coin and then we
figured out the different probabilities
that the random variable could take on
different values let me rewrite them all
here the probability that we get exactly
one head or zero heads actually let's
start there the probability we get zero
heads and that's the same thing as
getting five tails we figured out was
one out of 32
the probability of getting
one head
we figured out was 5 over 32
the probability of getting
two heads
probability that our random variable is
equal to 2 what was that i think it was
10 over 32
yes 10 over 32 or 5 over 16
over 32 which is equal to 5 over 16.
the probability
that we get three heads that was
actually equal to the same thing 10 over
32 is equal to 5 over 16. and that made
sense because the probability of getting
three heads is the same thing as the
probability of getting two tails and the
probably getting two tails should really
be the same thing as getting the
probability of getting two heads
and then finally or almost finally the
probability that we get four heads
that was equal to five
over thirty two
which also makes sense because the
probably getting four heads is the same
thing as the problem of getting one tail
right
or when one tail should be the same
thing as one head so that's why these
numbers are the same and then finally
the probability that we get all five
heads which is the same thing as getting
no tails
is one over 32 right the probability of
no tails is the same thing as the
probability as no heads so let's draw
this let's draw our our probability
distribution
okay let me draw
the
x
axis
that's not thick enough
let me draw it
do a different color
all right and just let me draw
y-axis
almost there
all right so what are the different
what are the different
values that we care about for a random
variable notice these are all discrete
values they're all particular
finite numbers that we we care that our
our random variable can take on and that
was actually a function of our
definition of the random variable right
this random variable number of heads
after five flips you can't have an
infinite number of values here your
value can either be zero through five
right and it can't be a a non-integer
even but the important thing to realize
that there's a this there's a finite
number of values that this random
variable can take on and that's why we
have a discrete
probability distribution
all right so the probability that it
takes on
let me just draw 0
two
three
four
and five
and this is our for our random variable
x so this is the number of heads in five
trials
and let me draw the high points first
so the first one let's see the high
points are oh they're all right there
see 5 10 30 seconds that's the
probability of 2 and 3 and they're the
same
let me draw a little bar graph
so 2 and 3 let's just say that this is
10 30 seconds right there
i'll draw them the highest because those
are the highest values
and 3 both hit 10 30 seconds
actually let me draw a little
differently let me make it so they touch
each other
so let's say 2 is there
and then let me draw 3
and 3 is also there
there you go all right what's the
probability that you get 1 that was 5 30
seconds so that's half of these these
two should be the same height so that's
5 30 seconds should be like
that and that's the same thing as
getting four heads so that's like that
let's assume that this 4 is down here
and the probability of getting either 0
or 5 is the same thing that's one so
that's one it's going to be one-fifth of
this height so it's going to be look
something like
that it's going to look like something
and let's say this last one is for phi
nope
the drawing is the hardest part
it's going to look something like that
all right
and so this is for 5 and this is for 4
right here
and this right here is 10 30 seconds or
5 16 10 30 seconds
this is 5 30 seconds and this right here
is 132nd
what i have just drawn is a binomial
probability distribution or it's a pr
not the it's a particular instance of
the binomial probability distribution
and actually as you get to kind of an
infinite number of values and once we
get to the continuous this will approach
the famous bell curve that you hear
about where
things actually
start looking like a bell
or it'll start looking like that and
we'll do some maybe i'll get excel out
and i'll i'll do it where i i start
saying instead of saying you know the
number of heads after in five trials if
i did this as you know the number of
heads in five million trials you'd start
these these bars would get very very
close together and you'd start seeing
them approach this thing that looks like
a bell curve
and this is a it's a very important
distribution one because it actually
describes a lot of random processes but
it's actually very important statistics
generally because a lot of times in
statistics you don't know the underlying
mechanism that's generating your results
and you just assume that there's just a
bunch of random stuff going on and they
just all kind of you just add up a bunch
of random events when you're adding up
random events that's like counting the
number of heads and then you end up and
you so you assume that a lot of things
have
a a well in the discrete case a binomial
distribution and in in a few videos from
now i'll show you the continuous case
which is the normal distribution and
that's in this this is really important
to realize because sometimes people make
that assumption about certain things and
the biggest one and this is probably the
most negative repercussions especially
in this type of financial environment
well they'll assume that some process
has a binomial or normal distribution
where it really doesn't right because if
you assume that something has a
distribution like this you start saying
oh well the probabilities that these
ends are really low but what if the
distribution is you know something like
this and i'll do more work on this i
don't want to get too advanced too fast
but the general idea it's really
important to understand the assumption
you're making when someone says oh we
assume it's a normal distribution we
assume it's a binomial distribution with
that said i'll just that's a little bit
of a of a nugget of why this is
important going into the future
but just to kind of review a little more
what we've already studied let's think
about this why is this called the
binomial distribution
well if you think about it the probable
when you flip when you flipped five
coins or when you had five flips of the
same coin
each arrangement you know i'll pick an
arbitrary arrangement of heads and tails
you know
each
circumstance of heads and tails i guess
i could call it you know that's one of
them five flips each of these have
exactly a 132 132 probability in fact
there's exactly 32 ways i can draw some
combination of heads and tails here
right so each of those have a 1 and 32
probability
and what we essentially did what in the
last video when we said okay what was
the probability of getting exactly two
heads we essentially said okay how many
of these circumstances or how many of
these i guess we could call it how many
of these permutations how many of these
permutations had two heads and we
counted them up and we got oh we said 10
of them have two heads and that's why
the probability was 10 out of 32 and the
way we figure that out is for example if
we said two heads we said okay
the one of the one of five flips could
be the first head and then one of four
flips could be the second head and then
we don't care about order so we don't
care if you know flip 1 was the first
head and flip 2 is the second head or
the other way around so we divide by 2
and we said that this was the same thing
as 5 factorial actually let me do it
color coded
this part
is the same thing as 5 factorial
over
3 factorial
and then 2 that's actually the same
thing as 2 factorial because 2 factorial
is 2 times 1
right so in general
in general let me write this down
the probability
that x
equaled n and this is for the x that i
defined the random variable the number
of heads i get in five flips of the coin
it was equal to
5 factorial
divided by
n factorial
right in this case it was 2 2 was n we
said was the probability that we get
exactly 2 heads
times 5 minus 2
factorial
right
and if you and i i encourage you to
review because it really is important to
get an intuitive feel of this i
encourage you to review the
videos i made in the probability
playlist on binomial coefficients and on
um you know this this flipping of coins
type of probability problems because i
go a little more detail in the actual
intuition of this but if you watch those
or if you have a little bit of
experience with this you would recognize
that this is the binomial coefficient
and i actually even have a video why
it's called the binomial because these
coefficients show up when you actually
multiply binomials binomials are just
things like you know if i just have x
plus y and i start multiplying it by
itself take it to different powers the
the coefficients of these tend to be
well they are the same as these and i
give you a whole video on on why that
well that's why that works and so this
is why it's even called the binomial
coefficient
and why this is called the binomial
distribution but another way of writing
this a shorthand
is five
choose n
and they say that because what were we
doing we had we said we had five flips
and we were choosing two of the flips to
be heads or in this case we have five
flips and we're choosing n of the flips
to be heads so this will tell you how
many of the different permutations
satisfy our condition and then we say
well what's the probability of each of
those it's times 1 out of 32.
so this is why it's called a binomial
distribution each of the
each of the values the probabilities for
each of the random variable values
there you can you can figure them out by
using your your binomial coefficients
anyway i just realized i'm out of time
again and don't worry i'm going to do a
couple more examples with this because i
really want you to get the hang of the
binomial distribution before we move
into the normal distribution see you
soon